Tijuana's downtown is squeaky clean its
main street is lined with bars
restaurants and shops and it sports the
unavoidable local absurdity which serves
as a tourist attraction these are the
images the city of Tijuana wants the
world to see in these days more than
ever the reality is a very different
Tijuana is sheltering almost 3,000
migrants from Central America so-called
Caravan migrants in the Benito Juarez
Sports Complex now with the number of
migrants we have in town the situation
is under control and manageable we're
cooperating and have the support of the
State Police and other security agencies
well yeah is that done they may have
control of the situation for now but
authorities expect that by the end of
the week
an additional 900 migrants will have
arrived that influx could make
conditions worse here things could
become unmanageable quickly a major
concern not only for city officials and
some locals a worry shared even by Cindy
and her three sisters the women arrived
here hours ago
making their way from Honduras in just
over a month they were separated from
other family members along the way Cindy
can't wait to get out of Tijuana and
into the u.s. we're going to ask for
asylum in the United States because we
ran away from our country we're afraid
in our country we don't have work there
but most of all we're afraid of the
violence Cindy and her sisters know that
asking for asylum in the u.s. is one
thing but that actually qualifying for
and getting it is much harder everybody
has gone has hope hope or not others
don't want to take their chances
starting the legal asylum process is not
an option for them
somebody I'll take the risk and jump the
fence for the last four days another
Honduran migrant has been sheltering in
Tijuana Francisco says he lost faith in
the u.s. asylum process why I don't want
to ask for asylum because I heard that
out of a thousand people just about ten
get asylum Tijuana for most of the
migrants just a layover on their journey
to their final destination the United
States of America this family here to
request asylum volunteers at the border
crossing are helping them with the
application which can take at least two
months to process that's a long time to
wait without work or shelter for or a
Leo his wife and four children their
journey from Guatemala already took a
month having to wait here is what
worries us we can't stay outside for so
long it's very cold
if two quanah's government gives us the
chance to work then we'll stay and see
how we can get into the US the local
government has assured migrants that
they can work here
but some experts doubt the city can
support so many in the long term Midori
adore this year they meet there are
around 7,000 jobs that could be offered
to both Mexican US and migrants the
local manufacturing industry could
employ some although it currently
doesn't have much hiring capacity not in
any psychopathy the absorption the NGO
that's helped the caravan pueblos
sinfronteras is keen to point out any
opportunities the aid workers want to
keep the migrant spirits high and
convince them of the dangers of crossing
the border illegally but they be Adam
West's there are 20,000 jobs and
construction that even offer training to
those without experience more than 500
people could die in a year when tensions
are high because there's a lot of
violence the NGO is urging migrants to
be patient but the lack of shelter and
hostile atmosphere in Tijuana is fueling
their despair more and more of them are
considering climbing the wall or even
swimming around it
Vladimir is one of them we're thinking
about crossing by sea wait until the
waves go down then take your chance the
migrants have little chance of being
granted asylum in the US under the trump
administration although there's a bit
more hope now that a US Court has barred
trump from denying asylum to those
entering illegally some families are
prepared to risk everything to try
if they don't let us in through the
ports of entry we'll have to jump the
wall there's no other way the biggest
risk is on the other side we could get
killed but we have to help each other
cross the barrier the migrants aren't
currently considering jumping the wall
on mass but they're also not ruling out
protest action to demand faster
processing of asylum requests more
Central American migrants are still
making their way towards Tijuana they
face a dilemma jumped the wall or enjoy
the uncertain wait for asylum